wanna do comrade I read your comments
and this week on thug notes we go on
hand with Animal Farm by George Orwell
it's all gravy up at the Manor Farm till
one night a prize boy by the name of old
major has a trippy ass dream
so this porker hollers at his animal
homies to preach some of that raw gospel
may just say that men are the only
creature on the farm that consume
everything but don't produce nothing
which means the only thing standing
between animals and righteous living is
stepping to and stomping their
two-legged oppresses rebellion dog one
night animals rise up and kick farmer
Jones and his boys straight to the curb
finally the boss of their own turf the
animals redubbed this bad boy animal
farm and lay down a new rap called
animalism up in this crib the main verse
is that all animals are equal after the
dust settled two pigs named Napoleon and
snowball start calling the shots thing
is they always getting up in each
other's grill with some humans try to
throw down and take back the farm those
animals don't play they straight beasts
these fools and send them packing then
the pole in and snowball start beefing
about the idea of building a windmill
when the other animals start side with
snowball Napoleon gets all crunk and
chases them off the farm another pig
named Squealer start telling everybody
that snowball was nothing but a snitch
and a traitor now while all the other
animals busting their ass building a
windmill the pigs realize that some of
the swag they need they just can't give
them their own so they hit up their
two-legged enemies and start trading
with them on the Reg over time the 7
Commandments of animalism get twisted
little by little until one day only one
remains all animals are equal but some
animals are more equal than others
eventually the pigs get so crooked that
they start strutting exactly like humans
walking two-legged with whips of
oppression in a
and in the end st. nobody that can tell
the difference between pigs and humans
looks like we're back where we started
listen up comrade this book ain't just a
story about animals on the real oil-drop
is some mad allegory about the rise and
fall of the Soviet Union see the pigs
representing the top dogs of the
Communist Party
Napoleon stands for style the Soviet
dictator
whereas snowball really beat Trotsky the
communist leader whose beef with Stalin
got his ass slunk out of Russia squill a
smooth-talking tendencies representing
prompted a newspaper that spit lies to
the people in order to further stylish
cars old major is a mix of Karl Marx the
og commie theorist and Vladimir Lenin
the brain behind the Revolution when old
major preaches to the animals this is
why I've got the same flavor as the end
of the Communist Manifesto the
Communists openly declare that their
ends can be attained only by the
forcible overthrow of all existing
social conditions working men of all
countries you tonight also the animals
revolt in chapter 2 echoing the
Bolshevik Revolution of October 1917
against the Tsar will be mr. Jones in
the store and the humans attempt to
retake the farm in chapter 4 wrapping
the silver wall between the Russian
loyalists and Bolsheviks in 1918 now of
all things why did all well use animals
to chop gangs out the Soviet Union well
check this quote from Karl Marx's
economic and philosophical manuscript of
1844 the worker and his human functions
no longer feels himself to be anything
but animal what his animal becomes human
and what his human becomes animal but
Animal Farm ain't just going off about
one point in history this book offering
some legit truths by all humanity cuz no
matter who you went sour can corrupt
your mind and even the real is home he's
like boxer I liable to start worshipping
a crooked ass leader but you know what's
mad ironic be if you're keepin it
literal up in here the revolution that
went down a man of
was actually legit by definition a
revolution ends where it began because
the poor key players that started out
getting about a human oppressors are now
the ones doing you don't show you colors
and get yourself a fine those t-shirt
son cos next week player
[Music]